maître philippe de beule bonjour merci à
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors une date symbolique 1 pour ce 11
mars est ce que c'est important pour les
familles des victimes justement d'avoir
établi cette journée nationale de
commémoration
oui bien sûr c'est toujours important de
commémorer à tous et à sang tous ces
attentats qui ont frappé l'europe ces
dernières années mais il ya aussi
l'action et il y a aussi le la pensée
aussi à ceux qui sont morts et ceux qui
sont blessés
vous êtes l'avocat des victimes des
attentats on l'a dit du bardo à tunis
mais également du bataclan à paris ce
qu'aujourd'hui les familles des victimes
ont un besoin de reconnaissance
elles ont surtout besoin d'un soutien un
soutien matériel et un soutien
psychologique
et c'est là où le rôle de l'avocat est
important parce que au-delà de défendre
le droit le droit des victimes il y à
relais entre des institutions et
l'avocat et un suivi avec les victimes
j'ai beaucoup de victimes qui souffrent
qui ont une forme d'un sensation
d'abandon ce que je comprends et
d'ailleurs j'ai une victime du bataclan
qui en italie qui sont je suicide encore
dimanche soir bon là c'est vrai qu'il
serait d'italie est frappé de plein
fouet par le coronavirus et donc et on
on vit dans une atmosphère vraiment
délétère en italie bon donc l'avocat est
là pour être un relais parce que vous
savez les symboles c'est bien les
lâchers de ballons c'est bien mais c'est
pas suffisant il faut vraiment savoir
quel est l'avis du victimes du
terrorisme après un attentat c'est c'est
quelque chose de très lourd
parmi les personnes que vous représentez
il ya encore des séquelles qui sont très
importants chez chez ces personnes qui
ont vécu certains actes terroristes
oui bien sûr comme je vous le dis j'ai
reçu un sms message d'une de mes
clientes du bataclan qui sont géo
suicide j'ai aussi notre personnes
victimes des attentats du bardo qui
était dans un dans une fragilité
psychologique terrible et bon
heureusement ça va un petit peu mieux
mais j'avais des craintes pour pour elle
pour pour la suite
il faut savoir que des victimes du
bataclan se sont suicidé il ya un
sentiment d'abandon très fort par
rapport si vous voulez à à ce que l'on
met ce que l'on dit dans la presse ou
les manifestations il n'ya pas de suivi
après il ya la télévision qui vient on
fait un discours et puis après la
personne qui a subi un attentat
elle est chez elle et elle est perdue
parce qu'il faut il ya plein de
démarches à faire non seulement il ya
les soins pour ceux qui sont blessés
puis après il ya toutes les démarches
administratives que l'on entreprend avec
le fonds de garantie jusqu'au mans qui
est qui est là pour indemniser les
victimes mais tout ça c'est du travail
et bien souvent les victimes sont seuls
alors ce 11 mars c'est également la
journée européenne de commémoration des
victimes elle a été instituée après les
attentats de 2004 à madrid et est ce que
vous souhaitez que l'hommage national
qui sera rendu aujourd'hui cette date
entre officiellement dans le calendrier
que chaque année justement en france on
commémore voilà les les victimes du
terrorisme est-ce que ça serait une un
moyen de ne pas les oublier
confection date c'est une question de
détail soit le 11 mars le 11 novembre
enfin donc 13 novembre
peu importe ce qui ce qui est important
c c'est ce que doit faire l'êta
poursuivre des victimes pour le moment
il ya peu près de 164 morts et des
milliers de blessés
l'étape encore les suivre et les aider
j'ai fait plusieurs démarches pour
retrouver des emplois pour pour des
certaines victimes j'ai fait demande
auprès d'autorités politiques qui n'ont
rien fait et c'est là où le bât blesse
c'est dire que le politique aime bien
faire des discours lorsqu'il ya les
médias qui sont là pour rassurer les
gens mais en fin de compte j'ai pas par
expérience personnelle j'ai eu un refus
du président macron de recevoir les
victimes du bardo qui avaient des
doléances de lui présenter et des sujets
très grave a exposé voilà donc très bien
qu'ils fassent un petit discours avec le
roi d'espagne place des trois autres du
trocadéro et bien grand bien lui fasse
mais c'est pas c'est pas assez sérieuses
et pas c'est pas suivi par la suite voit
très bien en tout cas merci beaucoup m
philippe de veulent d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat des victimes des attentats du
bardo à tunis également du bataclan
paris